cancer treatment requires aggressive
intervention but some drugs such as mono
methyl or is that in E a too toxic for
systemic administration because they
damage healthy cells as well as tumor
cells however attaching the drug to an
antibody targeting a surface protein
highly expressed on tumor cells can
prevent collateral damage different
linkers can be used to attach a drug to
an antibody these linkers are designed
to break down and release active drug
only after antibody drug conjugate
enters the tumor cell
this allows drugs to be activated only
at the tumor site
unfortunately certain factors can weigh
lay the conjugate before it gets there
first the linker can break releasing the
drug from the antibody prematurely the
free drug can then kill healthy normal
cells leading to a variety of side
effects including peripheral neuropathy
to prevent this efforts to engineer more
stable linkers less likely to break are
underway
second healthy cells can ingest antibody
drug conjugate
in most cases conjugates are ultimately
recycled back out of the cell without
causing damage
conjugates that are not efficiently
recycled can kill the cells in which
they're retained a small percentage of
the antibody drug conjugates ultimately
reached the tumor but even conjugates
that reach the tumor may not kill tumor
cells for example if the cell doesn't
internalize the conjugate the drug can't
kill the cell efforts are underway to
ensure that protein selected as new
conjugate targets get internalized into
the cell in successful therapy tumor
cells internalize sufficient numbers of
conjugates
once inside the cell conjugate linkers
may be broken for example by lysosomal
enzymes active drug then enters the
cytoplasm inflicting lethal damage one
common mechanism to kill cells is to
inhibit assembly of microtubules which
are essential for cell division
two missiles that cannot divide die by
apoptosis active drug released from
dying tumor cells can kill nearby cells
including other tumor cells and stromal
cells antibody drug conjugates target
the toxic effects of chemo therapeutic
drugs to tumor cells thereby minimizing
the type of collateral damage that leads
to unwanted side-effects
you